[Music]
I was about 15 years old I was at a
party college party and was drinking
underage you know and somebody slipped
something in my drink and the next thing
I knew I woke up to someone I didn't
know on top of me and unfortunately
penetrating me and I got so scared and
screamed and luckily had other people at
the party who'd busted down the door and
came in but it'd already been too late
I'd already been assaulted it was really
hard because I thought at the time that
nobody would understand and fifteen
years old at a college party so a lot of
people put the blame on me so I'm
hearing the me2 movement sorry it uh I'm
glad that women people are getting out
there and finally speaking up for
survivors because it's really important
for us to do that
be strong and always speak up go get
help
no matter how much or how many people
you have to push out of the way it was
never your fault
always press charges because they need
to pay for what they did to you what
they did to us they can't keep doing it
over and over again so speak up and say
something when I was a busser and our
strand we had a bunch of other workers
in the kitchen and they would always
like walk by and good like I grabbed
your ass it's really I don't know I
thought it was just a thing and it was
like oh well you just keep working it
was just something he didn't really pay
dented Jews they grabbed grasp for no
reason I didn't think it was okay it was
very awkward and but I mean you work in
it you need the money so money was good
maybe give advice to other people who
might be
No aah I've learned to punch people I
probably don't goodbye scene with a
fence shape of it I guess if girls
actually made it some type of scene out
of it when it happens I guess that would
change things dramatically rather than
you know letting it happen and then
going to imagine or secretly and trying
to discuss it that never went anywhere
just recently I was in an uber on my way
home I had had some drinks and I kind of
dozed off
I made the mistake of sitting in the
front seat and the guy that was driving
my uber driver actually reached over and
put his hand up my dress speak up
reported I mean it's happening to more
than you know just me or anyone like
near me it's happening everywhere so
speak up and don't be scared or
embarrassed I mean you just had a really
imposing experience actually within the
last week I was in Barcelona and I was
getting into a cab at like my wee hours
of the night and I was like you know
drunk and lost and the cab driver
actually started to like grab and grope
me and like
kiss me and I like in the moment I like
you know it was just terrified didn't
know what to do
you know usually like I always think
about these things but you know when it
happens to you you are just like in
Chuck you know you don't know what to do
but yeah you know you don't think like
I'm on vacation like you know nothing's
gonna happen although uh but um no it's
it happens all the time so I'm a
professional bridge player that's secod
game it's very it's a man's world and
typically whenever I sit down and have
to play against um prob'ly some guys
they automatically assume that I'm
retarder I'm stupid or and I get
comments like oh little honey and how
sweetie and they might also ask me like
uh whose girlfriend are you like so
something like that that's what I just
what first came to mind I think and then
you beat them yeah of course I was in a
relationship with a guy and I was not
ready to be intimate
with him and he just kept pushing and
pushing and he would get angry every
time I tell him no and eventually it
started becoming more and more serious
and he would get aggressive and so I
finally broke off the relationship and
that was my only experience
I don't know how to start this I guess I
would say in relation to the me to
experience I think everybody has
experienced it I think for so long and
what I'm noticing from people who I'm
hearing their stories we've minimized
what we think is sexual harassment and
now people are more aware of I hate to
say this rape culture that we live in
and that we perpetuated a society and
I'm glad it's actually coming to light
and people are being held accountable
me too he's been happening for a long
time and I just think that is going to
be like a domino effect that the person
on the top has come down and now it's
been a trickle down to everybody else
but now it's out in the open and I think
now they know that they can't do this
anymore
and we were not going to put up with it
and they have a voice so I'm glad it's
happened I think that it's about time
that everyone speaks up and I know it's
not easy for people to actually say that
that has happened to them there's a lot
of shame that comes along with that
happening so I think it's a really
fantastic movement and I think we should
continue to move forward and bring all
of this to light a lot of time I find
that men can overpower women mentally
even and threaten them with stuff like
displacing them from the workplace if
they come forward or hurting them or
their family or people they live in
mentally or physical ways or just for
you know speaking up and I wish that
would just go away because we're moving
forward and we need to get out of that
era we women we need to be strong and
have a voice and stick together
I'm very proud and I'm I really admire
all the women who came forward and
shared their experiences with sexual
harassment and I hope I mean it's it's
very saddening but I hope this movement
will start an even bigger movement and
hopefully we can finally help these
women and give them a safe space to talk
about what they went through and also
you know raise awareness for such as
manager I think the meeting movement is
very important from a male perspective
parents need to raise their voice to be
gentlemen they need to understand that
until it's a yes that's a no and they
need to understand that yes can change
to know at any time and that until it's
a definite yes and always a definite yes
all the way through it's no
[Music]